The joe rogan experience.
You know,
I think some people would have been
different timetables and make it like,
to me of be happy masturbating.
I'd like forever for life.
I've looked at a canary or if you went
to jail for life.
For Life,
yeah.
I would totally just be happy
masturbating when it just like some
sweet,
sweet boy wants to suck your Doug did.
Unless it was like Justin Bieber style
or something like that.
So you would do it if it was a little
boy to do it if you looked under it.
Yeah.
No,
no,
just kidding.
No.
To me,
I'm happy with masturbation.
I think masturbation is great.
I have no problem.
Now if I'm in jail and I have nothing to
look at it,
I'd probably have to draw my own women
and stuff like that.
You know?
You wouldn't just go from memory.
You would go for your own after a while
you want to have memory anymore.
What'd you,
what'd you kind of be too foggy?
I have some memories from my childhood.
I would drop right when it got in there
and draw a vagina and boobs and stuff.
Just so I have references for what they
look like.
Yeah.
You would think that at least they could
get them some fucking porn jail man.
That shit was fake.
Right?
Where you're allowed to have sex dates
or is that real?
In some prisons they have it set up like
that.
They would,
they would allow them to have conjugal
visits where they're allowed to have
sex.
Yeah.
They do that in some places,
but I don't know if that happens
anymore.
Is that still going on?
Oh,
I see.
I never knew it existed to begin with.
Yeah,
it was a real deal.
I Dunno.
I'm not,
I'm not hip to what's going on in prison
these days.
There's a lot of God damn prison shows
on TV though.
Have you seen the one with the booty
bandit?
God talks about booty.
One of the most frightening things ever.
I'm going to load it up because you need
to to know that this,
this guy's like this waiting for you.
There's guys like this guy waiting for
you in prison.
Yeah.
The Buddhi warrior.
Okay.
I'm going to load this shit up,
wasn't it?
That's fine.
Sexuality,
sexuality.
You have it on twice somewhere.
No,
I only have it on here.
You have to eat your windows up.
Yeah,
but it's not the same thing.
This is something else.
That's something else.
I only have it in here.
Oh,
what's this one?
All right.
This is it.
I said plane twice.
I Dunno.
You're the fake tech support here.
I bet
you told us about the place.
Police told us you have the use thrown
out.
Oh,
is that what it is?
Yes.
Yeah.
Jesus.
This is the most unprofessional setup
ever.
Toll free call.
You can't sell free.
They're trying to sell me real estate.
Order that answer that live.
No,
but when lockup visited Kentucky state
penitentiary,
we met police jobs a long time in men
who practices are very different kinds
of homosexuality.
Well,
we have sexual dissolves,
right to is locked though.
All along be the or all.
I'm calling it all.
I'm gonna say so what are they
made him a happy woman.
[inaudible]
most memorable story that's police told
us,
this is why is even hale one of the
producers and I met this dude.
He talked now about this boom,
easy within a maximum security
penitentiary.
And he went on about it and thought
about it in the prison,
who he was.
Um,
more importantly may is,
but
oh,
it was a moment.
It looked low.
Boomi,
I haven't to bullying
what's more important?
Drank the water.
Who was that guy projecting like is that
it's,
I don't know,
feeling and he's just like,
everybody likes it more than water.
I don't know whether he's just trying to
be sensational for the TV show and just
like really freak everybody out or if he
just likes fucking people that much,
he just loves the booty down much I
think.
I think he personally would like to ask
some more than anything while he's
talking about how it's,
that's how the rocket in jail,
I mean you got,
he's the only one in jail.
You got to think there's a possibility
that he's telling the truth that
everybody's just running around fucking
everywhere.
Leah is a,
if you have probably like a life
sentence,
there's probably a good 70% of people
that just flip over.
I don't.
Yeah,
I don't think I would,
but I don't.
I'm not putting that situation.
You were in jail with this guy though.
That guy you will.
You got to give up the booty.
You think you can fight them off and
he's got a weak chin.
I don't like that.
You think could fight him off or no?
You don't like to wait?
Like if he attacks me,
give up the booty.
If he attacks me,
raped you.
Ah,
fuck.
I don't know that guy.
I could beat that guy.
Really?
You think you could beat this big black
dangerous rapist did?
If he likes as that much,
I could totally beat that guy.
Well,
let's see what this is.
How he would take the pussy tells guy so
it takes the boy pussy.
I like Blue Johnson went on to tell our
crew how he used to satisfy his sexual
desires,
especially during the 1970s and eighties
when he was most active in prison.
Security was more lax on see you on.
To me,
when I go see him,
I'll say
[inaudible] I'm like,
no mom,
I want Ya and how we can do it.
The easy way out of the hallway so
we can do this
easy way or the hard way.
The choice is yours,
right?
What just do Brian if said that to me,
all right,
take it.
I'd be like,
all right,
but let me go down on you first and then
like you would take his pants off,
right and I would just like fucking
start karate chopping his dick as hard
as I could.
Do you really think that's going to
work?
First of all,
you'd probably be hypnotized by it.
Like a Cobra to a flute.
I would probably look at that big giant
black fucking snake in front of you.
You might start out of fear.
I would probably grab it as hard as I
could and run as fast as I could to snap
it off.
The worst crop Magog glass ever.
You would be though the worst self
defense.
The structure of all time.
Probably just,
okay,
this is what we want to do.
I probably would do something deck
story.
I'd probably like,
could you imagine if you had,
this was your fucking plan.
Imagine if somebody hired someone to do
like a rape prevention course and you
were the guy and that you would come in,
you were totally unqualified.
I just,
we're going to grab the Dick.
We're going to run as hard as we can.
We've tried to rip it off.
You definitely people practicing like if
he's got his dick and it's on the floor,
do you think he's going to be worried
about hurting you or Gideon's tick
attached back to his body?
He's not going to spend the time to kick
your ass.
Trust me.
You pull his dick off.
The fight is over.
I called this move.
Picking up the phone Dick to take the
grab,
grab the balls as hard as you can and
just pull it up as fast as he can can
own book.
Imagine that.
Imagine if you were to do that,
like if you're like,
all right,
let me go down on you and you take,
you take his balls and both of your hand
and take two handfuls as hard as you can
crab,
you just dig your closet and just like
pull and and rip as fast as you can,
but you might be able to rip someone's
testicles.
What might be possible?
Yap.
Someone's Tuscaloosa have a good grip.
If you knew you're going to get raped in
prison,
you do something like those balls were
all sweating.
Don't they slipped right out.
Oh,
that's what you have to dig.
My nails are courts.
Ankle slips right out and then you've
got,
what are you going to do now?
He's going to beat the fuck out.
He tried to grab his balls.
Dig your nails in,
man.
Go for the bail.
Put your finger underneath the vein.
That's what that would be.
Your self defense would always be attack
the ball.
The ball is that dude in prison?
Definitely that style.
What if he punches you first?
Don't care about prices.
I'm going to write for his chin.
He punches you in the face before he
even makes you suck his dick just Bob
Bland.
Just to let you know this is how it's
going down.
Well,
I probably wouldn't wipe my ass too much
when I was in prison.
So even if he did knock me out and she
went for it,
you'd be like,
oh,
this shit stinks.
I can't go for this.
You would sacrifice and you'd be itchy.
All get used to it.
Probably get used to this guy scares the
fuck out of me,
man.
That guy is crazy.
It's fucking crazy things like half of
me thinks he's just all fucking fake.
I don't think so,
dude.
I'm looking.
I think it's true.
You know?
I mean,
I don't think there's a whole lot of
rape and he looks like cee Lo green
though.
I can.
He's like,
I know,
right?
You
had a ward,
they might be asking for trouble.
They bought
this will stay on,
they call it some sort of gangster
style,
you know it's fake,
right?
So you said you'll pay it then her man,
somebody be up in your,
but you know
Randy from American idol on that scared
of that guy when he was in his prime.
They wouldn't be safe for imagery.
Advantage either.
The camera man,
he's ripped the guy in and being in her
back then and as much starlight booty,
I
ain't got
no shame in my game.
This is not that I'm ashamed to admit I
am
warrior.
I'm a warrior.
I'm a booty stealing warrior to me.
I see the gay and that guy and to me it
just sounds like he says like,
I'm going to get here,
I'm willing to get his butt hole.
He and I'm like,
that doesn't scare me.
So jail for life.
Are you crazy?
He's probably murdered a gang of people
and he will fuck you up if you were
alone in the cage with that guy.
And he pulled out as black digging and
we go and do this the easy way or the
hard way and started dropping fucking
knuckles on your face.
You think if you jack,
I'm rip his balls off.
So you'd be willing to,
if I can get this guy parole,
do you be willing to do a cage match
with him?
No,
I'm not saying cage match.
I'm just saying if I'm in a cell with
him and he approaches me,
I'd go for it.
Oh,
I will totally suck your big black Dick
and then I'll go down like I'm going to
do it right.
Just start ripping shit up and you think
that would work.
Holy.
We're totally fucking snap his dick and
half and every good boy.
He was still in the cage with you and
now he's hurt.
Yeah,
it people are going to keep on doing it.
He's going to start crying until it
comes to your rescue.
We start kicking his little ball hole
wherever it falls were
fucking,
I'm Jesus little ball boy.
Where murder him from the decode.
Yes.
But what if as you're going down to go
to his dick,
he needs you in the face.
No,
because he doesn't know.
He thinks I'm going down on him to suck
his dick and I'm just good actor.
I'm a totally good,
accurate think you're going to come off
shit.
It all I think never asked.
You'll throw on a gay boys.
Oh,
totally.
I'll tell they break out and everything.
I would fucking,
as an analyst of a altercations,
which I am,
I'm an altar kiss altercation analyst.
I think you're fucked in this one.
I think he's going to be looking for you
to do something like that because
probably other guys tried to grab his
dick before you think you gotta be the
first person to find if I,
these guys,
he's going to punch you in your face a
few times.
If I look them in the eyes and be really
sincere with my voice and be like,
look,
I really think we should do this because
we're going to be in here for a while.
He likes rape.
What have you,
doesn't get hard.
Look good,
normal way.
I'll be like,
look,
first,
want to lick you off?
You know?
You know,
I'll say,
oh,
I can obviously not bright guy.
I could trick him with my words and my
eyes.
We doesn't seem that dumb.
He just seemed to fucking prison.
He got caught.
Well,
he's a criminal Brian.
Right?
A lot of them were just there doing so
much crime.
They just will get caught.
You gotta be smart.
Dexter didn't get caught.
Oh Brian,
I think he would rape you.
Okay.
I don't think he'd raped me,
but I think he'd raped you.
I think a,
we'd have a problem though if he and I
were in jail together.
Hmm.
I don't think you would not try to rape
me.
I think he definitely worked.
Really?
I think,
yeah,
I think he probably tries to record
everybody smoking cigarettes.
I was like,
wow,
I've got a question.
His gas tank,
why are we always talking about gay sex
and this shit cause we're,
we're tarting how many people are like,
man,
all they do is to book assholes until
this is fascinating fucking guy,
man.
This isn't just talking about gay sex.
What's fascinating to me is about this
guy being so brazen about it,
but he's just talking about it and like
he's obviously loving the attention and
all those cameras are putting on them.
So I'm trying to figure out how much of
this is true.
I'm trying to figure out how much of it
is just,
he's uh,
you know,
exaggerating everything to seem even
cooler for this TV show because he knows
they're going to air him.
I mean,
he's probably a fucking star now.
They have TV in prison,
right?
So they probably have seen this show and
so I'm saying that he probably went out
and tried to rape somebody that night
just to fucking celebrate.
Right.
I don't know.
What if you can probably listen to this
podcast and he's sitting there fucking
like,
if I ever get out of here,
I'm going to show this boy.
I'll be,
I'll be deputes asphalt school.
Don't worry about it bro.
He got them.
We get them before he comes near you x,
I would suck.
Ah,
there's no way we can end the show this
way,
but yet we are doing it.
I would buy that guy a fleshlight like,
dude,
wait,
calm down second.
That's not what he wanted.
Or the Guy Asshole.
Maybe he likes it.
I,
they have butthole flashlights.
It doesn't feel as good holding a person
down the hole.
You be in panic and your blood,
sweat and all that.
It probably,
that's what he probably looks forward
to.
Probably looks forward to.
The whole domination aspect of it is
we've officially crossed the line and,
uh,
talked about way too much gay shit on
this podcast.
No more gay shit.
The entire next podcast.
Yes.
Next podcast has to be a all gay humor
free.
Yes.
Um,
uh,
Brody Stevens.
Okay.